ciao rivers e benvenuti in un nuovissimo
vede a grande richiesta torna il
traduttore di marina oggi in particolare
ci occuperemo di ragazzi ebbene sì cari
ragazzi siete spacciati per che grazie a
questa innovativa tecnologia tutte le
ragazze da casa potranno finalmente
capire che cosa volete dire quando dite
queste frasi per adesso non sono pronto
per una storia seria scusami non gli
piaci abbastanza amore sentire del
nostro sasco voglio uscire apprezza che
ti stia chiedendo umilmente il permesso
ma va amore farà una serata tranquilla
tra amici discoteca fino all'alba
ma ti pare che la sento ancora la sento
ancora la sento ancora amore quale di
veto o non lo so quello nero per me un
vestito vale l'altro
basta che tu ti dia una mossa se decidi
tu dove andare a cena però va bene tutto
davvero scegli tu ristorante tanto
qualsiasi cosa ti proponga non ti va mai
bene ma l'amore è marina la youtuber la
seguo perché fanno ridere i suoi video
anzi guardi anche te che cosa stai
aspettando
iscriviti anche tu al canale di marina e
clicca sulla campanella per ricevere
notifiche san valentino è proprio la
festa inutile
non ho la più pallida idea di cosa
regalarti amore ma ti pare non mi ha
guardato il culo non li ho guardato il
sedere li ho proprio fatto la
radiografia solo un america tranquilla
ovviamente non è solo un'amica amore
vado a cena con i miei amici tutti i
maschi in realtà non sono certo che a
cena saremmo solo maschi ma se ti dico
che potrebbero esserci anche delle
ragazze tu non mi faresti uscire quindi
passiamo solo ragazzi amore ma quello
corto nero quello lungo funzia ma quello
che vuoi tanto sai che sei sempre bella
datti una mossa
ho fame stasera fa la brava mi
raccomando non fare la cretina ti giuro
che non so chi sia
devo avermi chiesto l'amicizia anni fa
glie l'ho chiesta io dopo ben tre giorni
di stalking e
ovviamente perché me la volevo non è che
non mi piace che ti voglio solo comune
amica non mi piace la m aveva trovato e
per mamma ma è anche per marina era
destino che ci incontrassimo ed iniziare
della mia ex premier ex anche la sempre
più quella in realtà ogni tanto la sento
ovviamente l'amicizia però non te lo
posso dire perché se però dicessi
scoppierebbe la terza guerra mondiale
prende pure cellulare non troverai nulla
di compromettente ho già provveduto ad
eliminare tutto il materiale
compromettente quindi prego guarda pure
amore ci sentiamo dopo che devo fare una
cosa che non mi scrivere per almeno tre
ore
amore devo dirti una cosa ma promettimi
che non ti arrabbi
so già che ti incazzerà i amore ti giuro
che non è come sembra
è come sembra forse anche peggio
no no tranquillo niente sono incazzato
nero ma se i social neanche li uso dai e
li uso li uso o anche i tre profili fake
per schierare meglio le mie ex non sono
abbastanza per te meriti di meglio
davvero non sei abbastanza per me merito
di meglio quella che è ma no per forza
bisogno di uscire con qualcuno qualità
non quantità sì certo
basta che respiri ma te l'ho detto avevo
il telefono scarico non avevo voglia di
risponderti mi fa ridere non pensar male
non sono mica quel tipo di ragazzo sono
esattamente quel tipo di ragazzo piacere
mi piace però insomma bellissima ragazza
ma non voglio niente di serio non mi
piaci abbastanza
e l'altra sera ero completamente ubriaco
mi serve una pausa
il problema sono io e non tu il problema
sei tu
si ok va bene come vuoi tu dai non ho
voglia di discutere
ti va di salire da me a vedere un film
ci siamo capiti eccoci purtroppo
arrivati alla fine del video
spero vivamente che questo video vi
possa tornare utile in diverse
situazioni
fatemi sapere con un commentino qui
sotto quali di queste frasi
avete sentito più spesso e soprattutto
ricordatevi di seguirmi su tutti gli
altri social facebook in serata e tic
toc
io vi mando un bacio è ci vediamo al
prossimo video ma d'oro